you don't have to be an avid watcher of
the network's fusion or Univision to be
familiar with anchor Jorge Ramos he is a
longtime fierce critic of President
Trump's immigration policies including
Trump's vow to end chain migration and I
am delighted he joins us from Miami
Jorge sure you are Lara I'm sure you are
totalmente en espanol weekend Spanish
Chakiris or we can do it in English
terrible so I'm not gonna do it in
Spanish practice but I do appreciate
that you mean by me I know that we don't
agree on almost anything but I think we
have to have this conversation and I
really appreciate that absolutely and
you were very nice to me after my RNC
speech by saying good speech which you
probably don't agree with anything in it
and I mentioned that in my new book by
the way Jorge so this is the rest the
only thing I'm gonna say nice about you
the whole day it's okay I'm ready I'm
just teasing let's talk about what
happened today in New York obviously a
botched terror attack okay and uh la is
another individual who came to the
United States as part of what's called
chain migration he was over the age of
18 he joined his parents from Bangladesh
and if he had been successful he
obviously would have killed a lot of
people he was also carrying a pipe bomb
do you have any further hesitation about
your support of chain migration policies
absolutely you know I'm not here to
defend any terrorists I think he should
face the full extent of the law my kids
live in New York City and in New Jersey
so they could have been victims easily
but I don't think this has anything to
do with chain migration I think it has
to do with law enforcement and with
intelligence to prevent terrorism but
chain migration is really family
reunification he's been in the law since
1965 and for me when President Trump
says that he wants to end chain
migration those are code words from
really is saying I don't want more
immigrants from Latin America and I
don't want more immigrants from from
Asia yeah I see what you're saying but
let's just differentiate what he's
talking about and what you're talking
about what Donald Trump is talking about
is not Tabar children under the
age of 18 who are whose parents are here
that's not what he's talking about
they'll still be allowed to come in and
parents will be allowed to come in so
it's just your adult children so let me
stay with me
adult children of green card holders or
legal immigrants and extended relatives
which has ballooned the number of
immigrants in the United States I think
today is it 61 percent of all immigrants
who've recently come into the country
are the result of chain migration so
we're not talking about minor children
spouses we're talking about extended
family members so just so you I do
understand that of course I do
understand that and then do you like to
be with your family to enjoy being with
your family yeah but I don't have a
right to go to any other country and
bring my entire family in your uncle
anybody that you enjoy I'm assuming that
you enjoy being with your family well
immigrants do enjoy being with their
family and nothing it is it is unfair
that when an immigrant in this case
commits a terrorist attack or a crime
that we blame all the 40 million
immigrants for what happened we're not
doing that therefore today we're not
talking about blaming illegal immigrants
who are here in the country we're
talking about this policy that makes
sense or not exactly this policy has
been in the book since 1965 family
family reunification and basically as a
matter of fact it was inspired by by JFK
and now the the fact that it's that's
that's a lot chain migration if you know
what's a migration I do understand that
but you have to say it first cousins
second the toys from great art like how
many like the whole thing I mean you
have a universal right to pick up your
entire genealogical chart to another
country have to ended but what President
Trump is saying is that he wants to make
America white again he wants to go back
to 1965 when all of the population was
white that's it's a nostalgic chain my
patient
hey Jorge well honestly honestly sure la
verdad
4502 love it love it up the chain
decoration applies doesn't matter what
color skin it doesn't matter if you're
from Europe from Sweden you want to
bring in your second cousin or whether
you're from Mexico so new policy will
apply to everyone let's go to Kate
Steinle you haven't comment on the Kate
Steinle verdict I'm wondering what your
thought was once you saw the verdict
that came down where mr. Serrat a was
only charged with a minor offense of
possession of a firearm he was here
illegally left the country deported five
times came back we have a dead young
woman first of all I'm I'm really
serving my condolences to Kate's family
I'm a father and I cannot even imagine
what it means to be what it would mean
to be without one of my my kids I really
don't want to say anything that may
affect them now when an immigrant gets
involved in a crime again that doesn't
mean that all undocumented immigrants
are criminals and terrorists as
president from is trying to portray them
that is not the case these these are the
facts immigrants are less likely to be
criminals or be behind bars that those
born in the United States happen in San
Francisco we cannot do that I'm sorry
okay are you conflating in that
statistic legal and illegal immigrants
when you say immigrants you're putting
both together correct no also there are
many other stories on University
Princeton University did a wonderful
study I just finished with this one
because I think it's important with on
talking about undocumented immigrants
not only immigrants federal prisoners
are illegal immigrants today 22 percent
of all federal immigrants are federal
federal criminals excuse me are illegal
immigrants that's Justice Department fat
but immigrants overall and this is
important immigrants overall are less
likely to be criminals behind bars
because the fact is that more immigrants
that you have let the less crime that
you have let me let me give you another
example
we know of course that undocumented
immigration has grown from 3.5 million
in 1990 to about 11.2 11.3 in 2013 well
according to the FBI crime violent crime
decrease 48 percent in that same period
that means exactly that the more
immigrants that you have in this country
so that was primed that you have so for
prime interest in this country so so
you're fine with just so I understand
sanctuary cities even if we end up with
dead Americans or Latino immigrants or
with sanctuary cities should remain
despite the fact that they perpetuate a
situation where 1 2 3 a dozen people
could be gravely injured at the hands of
an illegal immigrant who was harbored or
not turned over to the feds by a
sanctuary Authority that century
sanctuary cities are created precisely
to protect immigrants who otherwise
won't be protected I mean no no because
the rate' was attracted by the police
and the immigrant community is really
important and in crime decreases when
police and communities and when
immigrants collaborate that's exactly
what happens now why should we blame
immigrants for all the prime and the
immigrants we're blaming college would
be terrible and allows people come in
here who actually commit terrible crimes
Mexico wouldn't want us to send people
to Mexico who some of them are terrible
criminals I'm sure that happens Mexico
doesn't like that I don't blame them not
documented immigrants in this country to
move to another country with your whole
family or to go to another country and
your crimes there's no universal right
to do that and somehow we've read that
into our law which to me is you're
insane
right and you know why they're here
because of you and me they're here
because they do the job that we don't
want to do because they pay taxes they
create jobs I did a my brothers exactly
for us working for them
temple tell my Spanish I'm getting
better here we're gonna do it we're
gonna do it all in Spanish next time we
appreciate it